il avait fait part de son envie de devenir député européen
c'est désormais officiel
Jean Lassalle sera candidat aux élections européennes de juin prochain
c'est sans doute pour cette raison qu'il a refusé de devenir chroniqueur
de Cyril Hanouna dans l'émission Touche pas à mon poste !
Jean Lassalle conduira la liste de l'Alliance Rurale
qui rassemble des agriculteurs des chasseurs
des sportifs ou encore des élus locaux
qui ont pour objectif de défendre l'art de vivre à la française
Willy Schraen le président de la Fédération nationale des chasseurs
devait initialement être la tête de liste
mais il a laissé sa placeà Jean Lassalle
et il figura finalement en 3ème position
pour l'instant l’Alliance Rurale
ne dépasse pas les 1% dans les sondages
d'autant plus qu'elle a été très discrète pendant la crise agricole
alors que c'est pourtant un thème cher à la liste
peut-être que la candidature de Jean Lassalle
permettra d'enclencher une dynamique
pour rappel il avait rassemblé
plus d’un million d'électeurs
lors de la dernière présidentielle
l'Alliance Rurale défend des prêts à taux zéro
pour toute installation de jeunes ou nouveaux agriculteurs
et plaide en faveur de la baisse de la TVA
sur les hydrocarbures de 20 à 10%
Jean Lassalle souhaite également s'attaquer aux désert médicaux
et il demande l'installation simultanée des nouvelles technologies
comme la 5G dans les métropoles et les territoires ruraux
sur la liste de l'Alliance Rurale
on retrouve plusieurs sportifs nationaux
comme l'ancien joueur de l'équipe de France de rugby
Louis Picamoles
ou encore le médaillé olympique en tir à l'arc
Jean-Charles Valladont
la 14ème reine d’Arles
et ambassadrice de la culture provençale
Camille Hoteman sera également candidate
ainsi que Véronique Langlais
la présidente des syndicats de bouchers de Paris